the jurogan experience it just just uh
uh a month ago or whenever was that uh
texas opened up fauci said cases are
gonna
are gonna spike now yeah cases are down
and you hear what frauchie said
which is hilarious what do you say jamie
and i were talking about yesterday
they asked fouchy like why do you think
that the cases haven't spiked in texas
he said well obviously the people in
texas
are what how was how did he phrase it he
said they're behaving themselves yeah
behaving better and
they're behaving better and jamie's like
have you [ __ ] been in texas
yeah but isn't this also like uh like
just completely circular logic
yes where you're like okay so if i say
this is gonna happen and then the
opposite happens it's because of what i
said that was
you know what i mean that's what cuomo
was throwing on everybody's face in new
york
yeah cuomo was saying if you you know we
gotta lock down
because you didn't wear your masks you
ate the cheesecake you're gonna get fat
remember that he was using these [ __ ]
down-home analogies like
oh and i jesus i'll tell you what i
can't stand
which just like makes my blood boil is
when they
use your basic
freedoms as a negotiating tool like
they're like well if you do
x y and z then maybe we'll let you have
restaurants exactly
maybe we'll let you do this like what
the [ __ ] get back some of your freedoms
like you're now you're using my freedom
as a carrot on a stick
to get me to do what i want to do like
what type of sick [ __ ] is that
yeah and this is one of the reasons why
i called you one one of the reasons why
i wanted you to come here to do the
podcast because i i've heard you talking
about uh covet passports about
vaccine passports and i share
your uh your deep concern
about this idea because this is not
something that you're just going to keep
with covet vaccines if there's a way
that they can get you to show your
papers and to show whether you have an
app on your phone whether you're
you know whatever it is that you have to
have
in order to be able to freely travel
around the united states
they're going to keep that [ __ ] yeah
well and i said just like i said before
if you're just
looking at the bigger picture of it
you're like look this is uh and i think
objectively
the country went totalitarian for about
a year now not every single
part of it was as totalitarian as the
rest but according to governors out of
the
their own words they suspended the bill
of rights yeah and we've
we've been in a year living under that
like how long do you think we can go
in living in a totalitarian society
before that's just what our society is
and there's not really a memory of the
old normal or at least that seems like
the old times that's not who we are
anymore
we're already dangerously close to that
position and now we have this
opportunity
where it's like hey joe biden says that
everyone who wants to take the vaccine
will be able to take it i think by june
he said
everyone who wants it will be able to
take it and that's a perfect little
opportunity point
to go okay so we break out of it now now
we break out of it
now you can make a sound argument that
if the vaccine's available for everybody
the people who want it can take it and
the people who don't are choosing
to take the risk and now we go back to
normal life and at the same time
they're proposing this vaccine passport
which really
if you look at the proposals isn't a
passport it's an app right
with your your medical history with that
can you know your data can be tracked
your location can be traced all of these
things
but what they're talking about doing now
when we have this fork in the road
we could go back to being a free country
not as free as some of us would like but
at least
the way we used to have it right or we
can go to what is being
proposed and talked about which is a
national caste system where there's one
group of people
who have basic freedoms and rights and
one group of people who do not
they don't have the freedom to travel
they don't have the freedom to go to
events
maybe not to work ideas have been
floated out about grocery stores
that that's a national caste system and
also
just uh you know throwing away the idea
that you have any type of medical
privacy
from the government this is being uh
it's being done in collusion between big
businesses and governments
and this is already happening it's being
done in new york city
it's being done in other countries and
there were reports in the washington
post
in cnn about the biden administration
meeting with
these big businesses to say oh you know
what it's not really good enough to do a
local level or a state level thing we
need to have one national standard
so you're talking about a national caste
system
and if we embrace that man
i i don't mean to be hyperbolic but like
i think this whole thing is [ __ ]
like i really think this whole country
we are not going to come out of this
if we embrace the idea of now this is an
idea straight out of the chinese social
credit system
this is what they're proposing we do by
the way china already has the coveted
passport this is what china does
that's it no sense of like you have a
right to do this you have a right to not
do that
and come on you think they're going to
take that power and then this will only
ever be used for the covid
vaccine so logically it doesn't seem to
make sense if the vaccine is available
to everybody who wants it and everybody
who wants it gets vaccinated
who are we protecting yeah if these
folks are out there that aren't
vaccinated that are supposedly these
super spreaders
and that's what we're supposed to stop
right the idea is that these people
aren't vaccinated they're dangerous
and we have to you you're not being a
good citizen because you have been
vaccinated so what we're going to do is
we're going to keep you
from doing all the things that you want
to do and we're going to allow those
other people that have been vaccinated
to have those freedoms
but aren't those people who have been
vaccinated have those freedoms aren't
they
they're not vulnerable right isn't that
the idea yeah so so
it doesn't matter it logically it makes
no sense
um morally it makes no sense but
it is an unbelievable opportunity for
the government to really keep
a a serious you know
level more of control but i think the
biden administration has rejected this
so far like there was a
there was a discussion where they were
asked and i think was what's her name
jen
saki she was saying that they have no
plans whatsoever
to do uh vaccine passports and that this
is not something that the body
administration believes in
yeah so what happened was there were
these reports that were out
that said that the body administration
was consulting with these these big
businesses on how to do it there was a
big
uproar about it and then when she was
asked she was like no no we're not going
to do that
and ultimately i think that's quite
possibly what ends up happening
like i think oftentimes they put out
these feelers
to kind of see what the people are
willing to take like going to war with
syria
yes yeah it gets a little bit too much
pushback we're going to back off
remember when they tried to regulate the
internet during the obamacare yes
the sopa bill or whatever they put it
out there everyone lost their [ __ ]
not yet not yet okay not quite ready but
it's so
that might be the case and then there's
all these other arguments you know like
just the practicality of it
i mean like look if you say you have to
show a driver's license
before you vote people will lose their
minds about how this is racist because
poor people and black people
disproportionately tend to not have
driver's licenses
so what is an app on a smartphone i mean
how do you think that's going to work in
practice
if you're saying you need that to do
these basic things um so there's all
types of these problems of how you would
implement it
but it's still worth noting that they
floated this out
like there are these people in our
government who would
go chinese fascist on us
if they if they could if they could
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience